when you mentioned the holidays this
Thanksgiving is set to be the busiest
air travel period since the start of the
pandemic according to AAA four and a
half million people are expected to fly
to their destination this year up nearly
eight percent from 2021. Chris Van
Cleave is at Chicago o'hare's airport
with a look at how airlines are handling
the crowds
bye little baby
Kathleen alfredson a nine-month-old Sean
got to Chicago O'Hare nearly four hours
before their flight Monday night hoping
to miss the Thanksgiving travel rush I
never traveled during Thanksgiving and I
I don't want to it looks too busy and it
is busy the more than 2.3 million who
pass through TSA checkpoints Sunday
topped the same day in 2019. it's the
most important holiday of the year for
us Omar redress oversees United's
Chicago Hub at one of the country's
busiest airports we plan and plan and
plan throughout the year United's hired
15 000 new employees Pilots flight
attendants mechanics customer service
agents ramp employees and we find
ourselves in a very healthy position to
deliver the Staffing needed to fly the
schedule we're promising but Airlines
struggled during the summer canceling
nearly 45 000 flights and delaying over
400 000 more Transportation secretary
Pete butterjudge do you feel more
confident than you did say Fourth of
July definitely more confident than uh
what I saw this summer there is a gap to
close though uh before we have a system
that I'm going to believe is fully
resilient for some of the shocks that
can that can hit air travel any given
day thank you helping passengers avoid
shocks as Edwin Gonzalez at work by 3
A.M he logs 10 miles of walking a day
making sure the check-in process goes
smoothly helping here stopping here
helping the customers calling me for the
machines
I'm constantly I don't know Non-Stop and
before anyone's non-stop pushes back
from the gate twins Corey and Courtney
Wimberley are making sure their bags go
with them working this Thanksgiving will
be a family affair does it make work in
the holiday a little better that you
guys get to do it together
oh way better to work with my brother uh
on the holidays work out here and have
some fun and get the job done
Airlines know this this week is a big
test United is moving nearly half a
million people a day and so far so good
in fact the airline tells us they've
even seen a bump in last minute bookings
people deciding just now they want to
travel for the holidays Gail
okay Chris thank you